I think fashion can go three and I think
it should to agree i think it will take
the time for everyone to change how they
produce their goods and research and
resource kind of fabrics and countries
where these things are done there they
were an appropriate way for the
environment and for the people who are
making these these these products but I
it is going green and the companies that
have either launched as a green company
or doing products that are green have
been successful so obviously that's a
sign that it's working and people are
moving that direction it obviously is
healthy for business to which I think
has been in a lot of cases / /
throughout history if that's some of the
people desire it it actually helps move
the next